hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Socrates as a
person as a teacher as a martyr and as
we might call a philosophical hero left
a really massive impression upon those
who were concerned with philosophy and
Athens that's why we see multiple
schools of philosophy emerging from you
might say from the Nexus of his teaching
and his his way of life and his
friendship in the Stoics look to him
particularly as an ideal as an exemplar
of the way that a person ought to be
quite a lot of the things that that
they're they're saying about him are
borne out by what we have in the
historical record from Xenophon and
Plato about Socrates and what I want to
look at here is epictetus picture of
Socrates what made Socrates such a great
guy then we should emulate him you
notice that Socrates is brought up as an
example through Oh Epictetus discourses
it really comes together in book four
though and so I've got quite a
things on the board here that he talks
about what's particularly interesting is
that Stoics do in fact care about what
people think of them but they care only
about what people whose opinion really
matters whose judgment really matters
because it's well informed about the
nature of the good for human beings and
how human beings want to behave and
relate themselves to each other and to
to themselves and so epictetus will
actually say at one point in Chapter
seven a book for that Socrates is the
kind of person that he cares about that
he wants to appear good in the sight of
that he would like to have had a good
impression of him of course Socrates by
this time is long dead but he's using
Socrates is sort of a stand-in Socrates
is the kind of person whose opinion
Epictetus would would greatly value
other people's not quite so important in
Chapter four
he talks about Socrates as being the
kind person who took circumstances as
they were given to him and so he doesn't
fight against things he doesn't
cooperate with evil of course as a
matter of fact Epictetus brings up
Socrates and his refusal to collaborate
with an unjust execution of an Athenian
citizen which is recounted by Camus
Socrates in Plato's works
Epictetus brings this up as an example
of Socrates justice and Socrates not
allowing other people's threats you know
externals to interfere with keeping his
Faculty of choice in accordance with
nature but epictetus talks about
Socrates in this case as being somebody
who is able to enjoy leisure
while they you know sitting around
talking in the the gymnasium talking in
the parks with young man about
philosophy but when it comes time for
him to go on the military campaign he is
equally happy to go on military campaign
and fight against whoever he's supposed
to
in that case follow orders we know that
Socrates did in fact fight as a soldier
for Athens and he says Socrates is not
the sort of guy who when he's on
military campaign is gonna say oh what
was me I don't have the leisure anymore
to chat with the young man about a
philosophy he's ok with it he's he's
taking things as they come he is another
way to say it in the stomach vernacular
is to have his will in accordance with
the way things turned out so what that
means is that he's somebody who's serene
his he is he's happy he is unhampered
unhindered he's free so again he
provides an example of what stoicism
holds out to us as a promise in Chapter
five which has to do with contentious
people he's presented as somebody who
was a great example in managing his
relationships particularly his household
relationships well so epictetus will say
Socrates Worf very firmly in mind that
no one has master over another's
governing principle he willed
accordingly nothing but what was his own
and what was that now to try to make
other people act in accordance with
nature for that does not belong to one
but while they are attending to their
own business as they think best himself
nonetheless
to be and to remain in a state of
harmony with nature attending to his own
business to the end that they may also
be in harmony with nature he actually
calls Socrates there the good and
excellent man all right
later on he talks about in the same
chapter he parses this out in terms of
his home life and if you don't anything
about Socrates he he had a wife who is
rather contentious let's say and he had
children who were a bit of a
disappointment so he says all of this is
what Socrates bore in mind as he managed
his house putting up with a Jewish wife
and an unkindly son for to what end was
she shrewish to the end that she might
pour all the water she pleased over his
head and might trample underfoot the
cake yeah what does that to me if I
regard these things as meaning nothing
to me
well this control over the moral purpose
is my true business and neither shall a
tyrant hinder me against it nor the
multitude the single individual nor the
stronger man the weaker nor bad kids or
you know a wife who's it who's kind of
troublesome neighbors he doesn't give in
to the threats of people who say you
better stop doing philosophy as a matter
of fact at his trial he says I'm gonna
keep doing it no matter what so you're
probably going to have to put a stop to
me so you know that's another part of
the picture in Chapter eight Epictetus
says something else that's very
interesting he brings up the fact that
people would go to Socrates and asked to
be introduced to philosophers not
thinking Socrates himself to be a
philosopher and they wanted to be
introduced to Sophists to people who
weren't really philosophers and did
Socrates get upset about that and say I
don't know why you're bothering with
those people I'm the real deal no
Socrates very calmly and serenely said
sure I'll introduce you to Prodicus I'll
introduce you that this guy over here
why because Socrates was concerned not
with appearing to be a philosopher not
with being thought to be a philosopher
what other people what actually being a
philosopher doing what it is that a
philosopher want to do having the focus
on the things that really matter in
Chapter 12 of book 2 Epictetus is a
great example about how to carry out
inquiry with others and uses Socrates as
an example there of how the stoic want
to be here so I'm going to actually read
this a little bit of life with some
commentary he says when people are
mistaken what should you do how how
should you deal with them should you say
they they're just uneducated that I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna try to work with
them it's impossible to do anything with
these people he says no the real guide
whenever he finds a person going
straight leads him back to the right
road instead of leaving him with a
scornful laugh or an insult so you
should also show the person the truth
you'll see that the fault is they're
ready to so long as you don't show him
the truth don't scorn him don't laugh at
them recognize your own incapacity how
did Socrates approach this sort of thing
yeah there is where it becomes very
interesting he used to force the man who
was arguing with him to be his own
witness he Socrates would continually
asked a person who said well other
people say X Y Z he would say well what
do you think in doing so he would make
that person into their own witness he
would he would call them to you know
make clear what it was that they were
committed to and then they would see
whether it was consistent or not this is
a way that one can actually make some
sort of progress he says this is this is
why he could say I can dispense with all
the others that I'm always satisfied to
have my own fellow disputed for a
witness and the votes of the rest I
don't care about but only my person that
I'm discussing this with for he used to
make so clear the consequences which
follow from the concepts that everybody
realized that contradiction involved and
gave up the battle so he gives some
examples here and if you if you look at
Plato's dialogues you're going to see
them what did Socrates do did he laugh
at people did he treat them badly did a
pull rank
did he appeal to Authority no he would
work with the person as he found
and try to get them to see where things
were not good for them where there were
conflicts where there were
contradictions and then try to suggest
some way past that and if the person was
ready to hear that
they would embrace it sometimes they
would get very upset with him and again
though he doesn't have control over that
so this is just a portion but to some of
the key points of
epictetus is sort of composite picture
of socrates as a stoic sage a wise
person or you might say an exemplar a
hero somebody who is to be emulated and
followed